le banc digne vers quitte à la banque
est monté sur son cheval noir
cette fois ci le vengeur blanc n'a pas
pu m'empêcher de le piller la
banque/finance un son cheval au galop en
ricanant
heureusement que casimir n'est pas là je
peux lire tranquillement mon histoire
préférée le banc divers contre le
cavalier bleu
le banc d'hiver se retourna en entendant
le cri du cavalier bleu léonard je te
salue
le cavalier bleu n'a jamais crié ni en
arche du salut
et on a réjouis toi je passe dans les
parages et décidé de tenir compagnie
pour une fois où j'étais bien tranquille
tu étais en train de lire oui oui oui
oui l'histoire du bandit vert et du
cavalier bleu voilà avec une histoire
pareille on préfère le film formidable
je me vois dans le rôle du le cavalier
bleu luttant victorieusement contre à
c'est un metteur en scène pouvait
reconnaître mon talent je n'ai entendu
dont six bêtes que dis tu
vous méritez d'être heureux d'être à la
merci mon cher léonard merci toi ça ne
me comprend ici d'ailleurs je ne te
quitte plus on misait pas pour une faune
que je trouve quelque chose
que dit et monsieur du ce nom je veux
vous avouer quelque chose oui
je découpais
je ne le dis à personne
oui mais en fait je suis metteur en
scène de films de cinéma et je vis bien
contourner les aventures du cavalier
bleu et du bon hiver est une belle
nouvelle
m et je vous entends le rôle du cavalier
bleu au mercy mais tu ne regretteras pas
ton soit
donc
je contracte police par contre à
monsieur du sne oui jouera le rôle du
cavalier bleu dans le prochain film
donnait en a
vous avez signé oui
donc voila
merci
voilà à vous ne regretterez pas votre
choix à m bon je vais m'entraîner au
revoir ouais c'est ça
revoir
salé france par françois bonsoir
viennent voir
je voudrais savoir ce qui t'arrive je ne
t'ai jamais vu comme ça aussi sur io no
comment ça écoute je te connais assez
pour savoir que tu as des ennuis et toi
tu me connais assez pour savoir que si
je veux savoir je saurai alors dis le
moi tout de suite bon d'accord j'ai j'ai
quelques problèmes d'argent voilà c'est
grave bien sûr il s'agit de mes études
qui ont pourtant réussi ton dernier
examen jeu c'est justement je viens de
recevoir la liste des livres dont j'ai
besoin ils sont très chers et la vente
de mes ballons ne me rapporte pas assez
je pourrais peut-être temps donné un peu
au nom du gentil mais je sais que toi
aussi tu n'as pas beaucoup d'argent non
empire je me débrouillerai
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
sur 19 vous préparer une nouvelle
compétition ce parti non moins chers
amis je m'entraînais être millionnaire à
miliana et oui mon cher ami ça n'a rien
d'extraordinaire
ce qui n'est pas normal qu'avec tout mon
talent je ne sois pas déjà mais lyonnais
comment allez-vous faire mais c'est déjà
fait chers amis n'ont ni honneur nous a
réservé une surprise
il est metteur en scène de cinéma alors
il m'a pris pour ton prochain film je
faisais un peu dette évidemment je
m'entraîne physiquement vous comprenez
bon à la plus tard à
françois j'ai une idée je crois que tu
es sans vie
[Musique]
le réveil qui sonne à nos oreilles quand
on a sommeil
ya le bruit des moteurs et des marteaux
piqueurs ghiberti plaire
ni temps ce n'est pas tout
heureusement pour nous sur terre il n'y
a pas que ces bruits là
lilian la musique
que vous les oiseaux qui vont au boulot
et mouthanna où
voir si op beau il y à la musique
que jouent les ruisseaux où les gouttes
donc qui fera pas car en comptant les
donjons il y a
que
du vent qui souffle sur la mer
la gare
et les accords acrobatique du groupe de
pop que tu préfères milliards
qui nous fait qui nous fait schmitt et
qui nous paie danser dans le
manu
j'en amis
le
[Musique]
je me
pour
[Musique]
non
là
enfin vous
m
[Musique]
soyons francs soit ne soit pas si timide
et un art ne va pas tu mangeais tout de
même
nom ça me gêne écoute s'il est vraiment
metteur en scène de cinéma et qu'il est
un petit rôle pour toi ça te fera gagner
assez d'argent pour payer tes livres et
que tu pourra continuer tes études non
non non je peux pas je sais bien que
c'est idiot mais non je peux pas il a
écouté attends-moi dehors je vais lui
parler
léonard
leonard
olli je veux voir oui il serait une
question à se poser
j'étais content passer et tu vraiment
metteur en scène de cinéma
tu as rencontré mois oui mais c'est pour
françois que je viens te parler
il faut faire du cinéma avec avec sa
tête en bois tu es vraiment méchant et
il a un très joli visage
dès qu il veut faire du cinéma
c'est à dire que la vérité la voilà il
n'a pas assez d'argent pour payer ses
livres et ils voudraient continuer ses
études alors je pensais que c'était
aller ça va tu as bien fait
je laime bien françois tu donnes un
tiroir
je les ped avance qu'il soit là dans
d'anciens de penser à lui on écoute
léonard je t'assure que tu ne le
regretteras pas à tout à l'heure
je ne regrette rien du tout
mais que se passe-t-il en cours
décidément il est impossible d'avoir
deux minutes à soi qui est là c'est
moins cher m votre vedette
qui m'a dit qu'une seule du ce manque
depuis qu'il me coin metteur en scène de
cinéma il m'appelle mais comment est ce
que je pourrais l'appeler
j'ai trouvé en très cher grande artiste
voilà - saint-léonard nous avons des
verts n'a qu'à bien se tenir
vous êtes très bien dès que votre
partenaire sera là nous commencerons à
tourner en fourrure c'est impossible non
pour toi est un ami très sympathique
mais il était incapable de jouer comme
moi ils parlent faut alors ne vous en
faites pas il joue un tout petit rôle
d'ailleurs voyez vous même il n'a même
pas de costume
ce n'est pas nécessaire puisque la
caméra sera toujours sur vous
[Musique]
un gros bleu romy votre tête ont tu
prends ton écran comme ça
merci maître vous ne le regrettera pas
voilà ça monte talents de comédien à les
spectateurs vont être bouleversées bon
alors très bien aller voyons voir voilà
placez vous ici voilà comme ça oui c'est
ça alors la tête un peu plus droite
peut-être un peu plus de regarder devant
vous enlevez votre chapeau enlever votre
rencontre mettant fontan françois allons
regarder devant vous voilà prenez l'air
fâché
satisfait satisfait
non triste triste
étonné d'étonner
assez parfait armé très bien françois va
chercher la tarte à la crème elle est là
à vos ordres de m
discute pas on tourne s'il vous plaît
attention à l'est françois tu es prêt
très facile attention
[Musique]
et droit
mais pourquoi tu fais ça leona aux
armées c'est très simple quand vous
alliez vous nettoyez jeu.fr
tranquillement mon livre à l'émotion du
sport le film est fini